[Music]
well the Carnegie Mellon pre-college
program is is great in that it's six
weeks long I don't know another program
and I've been involved with several
that's as comprehensive in six weeks you
can really impact the young musicians
life I don't usually get the chance to
just devote myself completely to music
and like being here it's just really
cool that I can do that this program
comes closest to really giving the
students an experience of what it what
it is like to be a freshman music major
you're gonna take there your written
make sulfate and all if you come here so
in the classes like they're specifically
designed like to people's levels at that
light and it's not like to your level I
okay it's not gonna be easy it's to like
the peak your level my favorite part is
the variety of it all I get to be in
jazz choir which I love doing for fun I
get to do opera and Opera Workshop the
faculty here are world class really in
many different regards it's not only
that their instructors at the college
level and doing it for a number of years
which they have but they're also still
in demand is performing musicians which
is really important I've worked with
students from Asia and Europe as well as
all over the United States that have
come in for the program over the years
we have repeat students have come three
years in a row already now they just
keep coming back because they realize
that they're just getting great
instruction here and they meet new
friends every summer and there's a great
social environment here it's really cool
people are really open to meeting new
people and like making friends and
getting to know everyone so you get you
really get to know like you get really
close everybody's hundred percent
focused on music I just came from the
practitioners like almost everybody is
up there right now like everybody's
known the practicing you should really
attend this program because it'll give
you a chance to work with people who are
as dedicated to music as you are
which is something that you might not
get as much at home or at your school
it's not just having a love for music
it's about being a performer too and if
you really truly think you should be a
performer and love music this will
really show you the right way
you